In this case study,
we're going to see
how we can create a photo
illustration of your work.
The idea here is to show
how a liquid battery works
for a final illustration.
So first, create
photographic bits and pieces
and put them all together.
Think of it just as if you
were drawing the pieces
and putting those
sketches together.
After I met with the researchers
for a brainstorming meeting,
I got all this
material from them,
including a diagram
that described my idea
to create a model of how
a liquid battery works.
This is the way I
imagined the shoot to go.
OK first, I would take an
optical quality cuvette
and would then pour the
mercury and the water
into the cuvette and
somehow suspending
with a clamp, a strip
of metal foam, which
is an important
part of the science.
And because I was imagining a
full container of this material
after making the
image, I would then
crop out the right
side-- we don't
need to see the
clamping device--
and then flip the left
side, or a small portion
of the left side,
over to the right,
to then make the full
container and the final model.
Now remember, this is
not a documentary image.
This is a photo
illustration for, hopefully,
a cover submission.
That's the idea.
OK, so first I start looking
at the cuvette, the vessel
into which I was going to
be inserting and pouring
all the components.
I put it on a light box
and liked what I saw.
The picture was going to be
simple and lit fairly well.
Then I practiced
inserting the metal foam
with a clamping apparatus,
to see if it was doable.
And it was, at least
with an empty container.
Sort of a dry run, so to speak.
So the next
photograph I took was
with the mercury and water
in the container, which
looked fine too.
I then discarded
that, by the way,
into the special container
the researchers provided,
and sort of started
all over again
and tried for the
next steps, which
was going to be inserting
the foam at a certain level
with the water.
I played a little with lighting,
by shining a tungsten lamp
onto it.
It gave a warmer
feel, which I liked.
Then I plopped it
further into the water,
to see how that
was going to look.
And again, I changed
the lighting,
by adding a little lamplight
onto this material.
So I was getting there.
Eventually, this is the
image that I wound up with.
Well, sort of wound up with.
And I'll tell you, frankly,
I was a bit nervous
dealing with the mercury and
pouring it out and dealing
with that and the
water, especially
while having the important
cautionary instructions always
sitting in front of me.
So again, making the pieces
photographically and then
putting them together
was the way to go.
Remember, this is an
illustration using photographs,
for the purpose of creating a
model of the technique of how
a liquid battery works.
And this is how I did it.
I'm using Photoshop
here, but you can
use other software, of course.
Take a look at
the real life part
of this, where we're using
one image for the receiver
of the piece on the
right side, which is
what we had been talking about.
So I'm first going to
select the right side,
copy and paste into the
image on the left side--
the container with
all the material.
Move it around a little
bit, see if it has
the potential of being doable.
It's not bad.
I think when it's flattened,
it will look better.
I think it can work, so I will
in fact flatten the image.
And if you remember,
we were going
to crop out the
right side, which
is what we're going to do here,
crop, make the image as full
as we can without the
right side cropping it out.
OK, that looks pretty OK.
And now, as we had previously
talked about in the animation,
we're going to flip
one side to another.
But first, in order to do that,
I'm going to expand the canvas,
to make room for the
new piece that we're
going to start working with.
So I am, in fact, taking a
piece of the left side, which
is what we talked about.
I'm copy and pasting,
there it is again.
And we're going to flip it to
make up for the empty side.
We'll just flip it horizontally.
Move it around a bit, and
with a little fudging,
we get a pretty nice start for
an image that we're getting to.
I decided to play more about
raising it one more level.
And so I went back
to what we have
seen before in another
image, where I basically
take this pretty good image,
select the background,
invert the selection so that
we have, in fact, selected
the liquid battery.
Copy and paste,
and you see here,
we have another layer of
just the liquid battery.
And went to Layer
style and went back
to our old Drop Shadow friend.
And I played with making a
drop shadow, which I did like.
I tend to think that
it just pushes it away.
And I think it
worked quite well.
Eventually, what I
did wind up doing
is playing a little bit with
putting a different background,
for example, making a gradient.
That wasn't going to work.
I didn't even know
what I had in mind,
but I really wanted something
a little more dramatic.
So going back to the
picture without the color
in the background, I'm
keeping the drop shadow.
I went to Adjustments
and decided
to invert the whole picture.
And yes, that's quite an unusual
image, but decided to do it
and play a little
bit with the hue,
to get that blue back to the
orange that I sort of liked.
It wasn't quite enough.
I increased the
saturation a little bit.
And there it is.
This was the final image that
I showed to the researcher.
And frankly, I think we
got ourselves a winner.
Unfortunately, not the
cover of the journal,
which I really-- we were
hoping that would happen.
But it did get the home
page of the journal,
and a couple of other home
pages of various journals.
And it got a lot of attention.
First of all, of course,
the science was important.
But we pretty much agree
that making an image
to draw attention to
the science really
is what this image
making is about.
I hope you enjoy this, and see
the thinking that is extensive
when you get into
something this complicated.